comes over the head and you go back to
one so we've got
one
two
three just take note that the foot
always turns cuz you'll be going what
bit should I look at next
well you see when it's here when my hips
are going to turn it's no good just turn
like that and leave this foot here my
big toe must feel the
[Applause]
energy so that my whole body's
coordinating so at any one point I can
call upon that
power
Hey Okay so let's try that number
three
so when it's here you want to feel that
you're you're
doing you don't have to show much but
you need to show
this of feeling
of going down in a in a ready position
it doesn't want to be out there and it's
about here like it's comfortable again
you come over the head then then the
strip no get that get that feeling as
one let me see that no you're settling
quicker than you're
allower a little better all right keep
working with that
right no that's right don't look if it
had this feeling if it had this feeling
to it it might feel hold it it might
feel like as
we that feeling right so it's going to
go and then it comes up like a wave
again okay very
good make sure your hands keep that one
gap between
them good that would
salt that's
better try hard harder try harder with
that
lowering that's it feel it feel it sense
it really sense
it
okay so you have a short rest I pick
these two people if you can face me this
way you can face me this way no no you
face the mirrors as well sorry okay so
we're going to watch them both as they
do it so don't stop each time
just try
to imagine we're not here you know
you're
doing your own thing it's very difficult
when you're under
pressure but in your own
time so watch one and then watch the
other cuz they're going to do it about
thousand times before we
stop
okay so who's the who's the clo nearest
be to beginner who's who's joined
recently okay right so I'm going to ask
you a question who's the most
calest okay so you don't have to be a
black
belt to see it but I've been working
with him on a special
thing but I asked you the question about
the
calmest but let's watch
again okay so let's watch again what I
the part I was working on was the
settling so it's not the lift but he's
he's thinking about that cuz he's now
getting what I call settling and
calmness in his body but here see that
lovely calm feeling as he goes down the
King goes down he's in a peaceful place
but he's actually like a wound up
elastic band he could come out at any
any
time look how nice there look how nice
and even it is you'll see even high
grades thank you you'll see even high
grades do it like this they
go you see how this one looks
peaceful and this one looks
aggressive so now I've become I've
become the aggressor and in IID you're
supposed to be saying please come past
can be fitted in it's too easy to go
well I can't do that or yeah but I don't
get nothing out of this doing it like
that I used to get something out of it
when I done it like
that so we've got
one we've got
two we've got three now this one he just
goes up a little bit straighter it
lowers and you a new
lower